this is an eight news now breaking news
alert
nathan town obama the traffic center
while the freeways are filling up need
to let you know that there's a bad crash
that is completely closed an
intersection that was closed by a deadly
crash just a month or so ago we're
talking about spring mountain and
decatur now the closest traffic camera
is down at flamingo and decatur looking
up to the north and you can tell there's
a lot of flashing lights but we get a
better view from a photograph that was
sent to us by hector mejia who is on
scene we'll get a live report from him
in just a couple of minutes but this
crash badly damaging that car no word on
injuries or any possible fatalities but
hector says there's a ton of debris
there and that police investigators are
on scene once again the intersection of
spring mountain and decatur is
completely closed here's how we're
suggesting you can get around with this
intersection closed for north south
travel go east over to valley view or
west over to jones meantime for east
west travel with spring mountain closed
real easy just go up to di or down to
twain probably easier to do flamingo
once again the intersection of spring
mountain and decatur closed by a crash
remember that's where there was that
deadly limousine crash just a month or
so ago but we'll have a live report from
hector mejia coming up in just a few min